foreign
[Music]
Book of the Dead there's a banishment
spell that declares be far for me o vile
cockroach more than 3 000 years later
we're still trying to oust these insects
but from Poison traps to hastily
brandished slippers cockroaches seem to
weather just about everything you throw
at them so what makes cockroaches so
hard to kill
there are nearly 5 000 cockroach species
99 of them live in a range of habitats
where they play important ecological
roles by recycling dead or decaying
organic matter and nourishing other
animals but a couple dozen species
adapted to live in close association
with humans German and American
cockroaches are among the most common
and they owe their resilience to a
combination of physical and chemical
adaptations
when it comes to old-fashioned removal
methods they're troublingly tenacious
and American cockroaches sensory hairs
or structures pick up subtle air
currents and rapidly send signals to its
central nervous system
the roach can then turn and Sprint away
within a few milliseconds and it's among
the fastest invertebrates ever recorded
reaching speeds of up to 50 body lengths
per second this would be the human
equivalent of running more than 300
kilometers per hour
and finding a hiding place is no problem
with its flattened flexible body an
American cockroach can squeeze into
spaces less than a quarter of its height
even if we do land a hit it can
withstand compressive forces of up to
900 times its own weight by Distributing
the impact along its body
and the cockroach's toughness doesn't
end there cockroaches can eat a variety
of organic matter including hair dead
skin adhesives and paper this is made
possible by an expansive set of
digestive enzymes cockroaches are able
to thrive even in nutrient poor
environments
roaches often eat decaying foods that
are low in nitrogen an essential
component of DNA and proteins but they
survive by storing nitrogen containing
wastes in their bodies and having a
resident group of bacteria recycle the
nitrogen into useful molecules for them
meanwhile German cockroaches will eat
their own poop vomit and dead or dying
Colony members without hesitation an
American cockroach will Frolic in sewers
consuming excrement and toting microbes
like staphylococcus aureus and E coli
but they'll rarely suffer any
consequences this is because they're
equipped with genes that provide
immunity against numerous pathogens
these genes are often duplicated many
times over so when infected the
cockroach's immune system efficiently
unleashes many antimicrobial molecules
cockroaches also have a slew of defenses
against pesticides when a non-resistant
roach walks on a Surface that's been
sprayed with a pyrethroid insecticide
for example the results will likely be
fatal once absorbed the chemical binds
to sodium channel proteins which help
propagate nerve impulses the pyrethroid
keeps the sodium channels open so the
nerves fire repeatedly and soon the
Cockroach dies
but if a resistant roach is exposed to
pyrethroids it'll be just fine genetic
mutations have given them sodium
channels that the pyrethroids can't bind
to the Cockroach also produces more
detoxification enzymes which render the
pesticide harmless and the Cockroach
simply excretes it as a waste because
German cockroaches reproduce especially
quickly populations May evolve
resistance to a new pesticide within
months
so far they're already resistant to 43
different chemicals but contrary to
popular belief cockroaches would
probably not survive a nuclear
apocalypse compared with other insects
cockroaches are only mildly tolerant to
radiation they would die near the sites
of nuclear explosions and would still be
severely compromised miles away
moreover disasters that threaten
Humanity also jeopardize the habitats
and buffets we provide roaches perhaps
the only way to beat them is through our
mutual destruction or maybe cockroaches
would find even more surprising ways to
thrive long after we're gone
cockroaches are curious creatures but
did you know there's a bug that gives
birth to its own clones who are already
pregnant with their own clones and
that's just the tip of the Honeydew get
to know more about the weird and
wonderful aphid with this video